en este problema nos dicen que la medida
del ángulo cooper es igual a 2 x 122 cv
pr este ángulo de acá me de 2 x 122 voy
a suponer que todo está en grados 122
también nos dicen que la medida del
ángulo gps es igual a 2 x + 22 es decir
la medida de este ángulo de acá es 12 x
+ 22 y a partir de esa información lo
que queremos hacer es determinar la
medida del ángulo rp s este de acá bueno
pues para determinar esta medida bastará
encontrar el valor de x y sustituirlo
aquí y para encontrar el valor de x
podemos plantear una ecuación utilizando
que estos dos ángulos son suplementarios
es decir que son ángulos que suman 180
grados y eso se debe a que están
formando la línea q s esta línea de acá
deja marco y el ángulo en color verde
este ángulo que estoy marcando en color
verde es de 180 sale bueno vamos a
escribir eso tenemos que 2x más 122 la
medida de este más 2x más 22 2 x más 22
la medida de este de acá es igual a
ciento ochenta 180 sale y aquí tenemos
una ecuación en x que podemos resolver
cómo sigue este 2x con este 2x los
juntamos nos queda 4x más esto de acá el
122 con este 22 lo juntamos más 144 44
es igual a voy a usar un verde más
fuerte es igual a 180 ahora podemos
restar 144 de ambos lados menos 144
menos 144 de este lado se cancela esto y
a la izquierda nos queda 4x
es igual a la derecha nos queda 180
menos 144 180 menos 140 es 40 menos
otros 4 es 36 entonces nos queda 4x es
igual a 36 y dividiendo entre 4 de ambos
lados de este lado se cancela acá nos
quedan 99 y por lo tanto x
x es igual a 9 pero nosotros no
queríamos el valor de x sino el valor de
la medida del ángulo rp srp s así que
este valor hay que sustituirlo acá y nos
queda 2 x 9 + 22 2 por 9 18 si le
sumamos 22 nos da 40 y de esta forma la
medida del ángulo fps es 40 grados